i'm shannon bream i'm bill hemmer i'm
kennedy and this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday july 28 2021
i'm lisa brady masks are back
thanks to a coveted surge that's also
fueling renewed debate about
vaccine misinformation especially on
social media
where exactly do you draw the line
between opinion
which should be acceptable but may turn
out to be wrong and
outright fabrications which in this case
is a life-and-death matter
i'm dave anthony millions of americans
have needed unemployment benefits to get
by in this pandemic
but thieves are also cashing in stealing
billions
of dollars there are cases after cases
reported of people who need the
unemployment but they're
told we can't give you this benefit
because someone using your information
already has a claim filed in a different
state or we already paid out this
benefit
to someone posing as you so it does hurt
real people
and i'm janice dean i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
covet cases fueled by the delta variant
are prompting federal health officials
to revise their guidance once again
recommending a mask even if you're
vaccinated depending on where you are
in areas with substantial and high
transmission
cdc recommends fully vaccinated people
wear masks in public indoor settings
to help prevent the spread of the delta
variants and protect
others cdc director dr rachelle wolenski
says they're following the science and
that the new science is worrisome
showing some fully vaccinated people can
catch and spread the variant
they're also recommending a return to
universal masking
at k-12 schools all teachers staff
students and visitors regardless of
vaccination status
not long after the tuesday announcement
the white house staff was told to mask
up again
indoors this just two months after
urging the public to get vaxed
or masked the more we learn about
this virus in the build of variation
the more we have to be worried concerned
president biden
urging americans again to get vaccinated
and not ruling out requiring it for
federal employees
but he also vows we're not going back to
lockdowns
that more vaccinations and mask wearing
in areas most impacted by the delta
variant
will enable the country to avoid those
kinds of disruptions
white house spokeswoman jen saki says
health officials are trying to save
lives
and our responsibility and the
responsibility of public health
officials
is to continue to provide updated
guidance
if it warrants from an evolving virus
the white house also continues a
campaign against covet and vaccine
misinformation that's led to republican
accusations of big
tech and government censorship through
social media but the biden
administration blames misinformation at
least in part
for millions of people still being
hesitant to get a coveted vaccine
well the misinformation certainly is not
helping howard kurtz is the host of fox
news channel's media buzz and the media
buzz meter podcast
and facebook is in the i would say very
familiar position of trying to play
ketchup and insisting it's doing the
best it can
while not being transparent about the
efforts and it has become
a major way for just outright lies and
fabrications about
the dangers of the vaccine and oh could
it be used to implant microchips and
people
to spread to some people who might be on
the fence about getting it
but there's many many reasons why i've
read all the interviews with people
who are still considering it who ruled
it out and it's a much more complicated
problem than the media coverage
sometimes suggests
well there's also been a debate about
exactly what
misinformation is for instance the wuhan
lab league story that first was
considered a conspiracy theory
now it's being taken much more seriously
right
that is a perfect in fact a classic
example
of how politics can affect
uh these big tech companies and what
they consider to be acceptable discourse
i mean until a few weeks ago you could
not post on facebook
anything defending the notion that the
coronavirus 19
originated in the chinese lab at
uh it was considered to be completely
out of bounds
well then more reporting show perhaps
was plausible bite administration
taking more seriously now it's okay to
post about that so i i think
one of the reasons is hard for these
social media
giants although i think they can do a
much better job and facebook by the way
declined last year request internally
for additional money and resources to be
spent
on getting rid of these falsehoods where
exactly do you draw the line between
opinion
which should be acceptable but may turn
out to be wrong and
outright fabrications which in this case
is a life and death matter because
some of the people who don't get
vaccinated could of course
catch the virus be hospitalized and
perhaps die then another question that's
evolved from that question
is where do you draw the line you know
about the government getting involved
in what information people can see or
not see especially when you have the
white house spokeswoman jen saki
using you know phrases like you know
we're flagging
you know certain things the government
should not be involved period i mean
these are private companies
and the government you know saki and
others later said oh she didn't mean
that facebook would do whatever they
wanted when she said
that the biden administration was
flagging problematic content
about covert vaccines that it's the kind
of pushback
that the white house would engage it
with any media company hey we don't like
what you wrote or we think this is a
problem but we think this isn't true
that's okay working together just fuels
the distrust
of uh silicon valley companies like
facebook
because then it gets into the question
of well is it just politically
um damaging to the white house to have
some of this stuff out there as opposed
to saying
seeing it in much more black and white
terms but i ironically
there was this huge uproar facebook is
colluding with the biden white house
after those comments by
gensake and then a day or so later it
was president biden himself who said
facebook is killing people
remarks so over the line that he had to
walk it back well it's not facebook
that's killing people
it's these 12 people who according to an
advocacy group
are spreading about two-thirds of the
covert vaccine
falsehoods online um and so
within a single news cycle or two the
biden white house was accused both of
colluding with and being at war with
mark zuckerberg's company
right and how damaging is that for the
white house to have to
backpedal on these types of things does
that in turn
fuel more distrust not just of social
media companies but of the government
i think the press largely gave president
biden to pass on what was a pretty bad
mistake
he usually chooses his words carefully
he's not somebody who throws a lot of
rhetorical bombs uh
as donald trump often did in the service
of
making news which he made a whole lot
more news than the current president
does and that's by design
so when biden just came out and said
they're killing people i mean i
whether you agree with that line of
reasoning or not it was
very out of character i think for the
46th president and when he had to pull
it back a few days later
under considerable pressure i you would
think there'd be a lot of stories about
what a big mistake this was by the
president
and there was some criticism but i think
he largely skated
there certainly have been a lot of
coveted vaccine myths
circulating which you know goes to the
sort of misinformation debate
from fertility issues to will it change
your dna is there something the white
house team
should be doing differently to counter
that maybe regular briefings with
doctors other
than anthony fauci for example yeah
anthony factory certainly has become a
lightning rod
especially for the right in a way that i
think is unfair it's not that fouchy is
a bug criticism it's not the fact he
hasn't made mistakes
in this pandemic but uh when you have
certain um
politicians you know saying that he's
the godfather
of copen19 when he's devoted his whole
life going back to the reagan
administration trying to fight
infectious diseases that strikes me as
unfair and i think is rooted in
the criticism he got when he was working
for donald trump
from the former president which and then
the promotion and effect that he got
from president biden
the problem is uh there's such a lack of
mistrust
and we talked a moment ago about
more complicated reasons why some people
are refusing or
very hesitant to get the vaccine a lot
of it clearly
is tied up with politics
red states or certain red states
compared to certain blue states have the
lowest vaccination rates
a lot of polls show a lot of
conservatives and republicans more
hesitant
than democrats and liberals to get
vaccinated but it does go beyond that
if you live in a rural area it can be
harder to find a place with easy access
i've seen people in interviews talk
about worrying about having to take a
couple days off from work if they have
the usual side effects there is an age
divide there's an educational divide
there's a racial divide vaccination
rates being much lower in minority
communities so
i think it's a problem that's not going
to be solved by giving out free beer or
free weed or free baseball tickets free
lottery tickets
a lot of folks say that the
persuasion effort should come from
trusted voices
in the community doctors who live in
your community
uh pastors for example uh and friends
and family i i don't i no longer believe
uh that it's a problem that can be
completely solved by government
and i do think the other interesting
twist here in the media coverage
is that now there is growing
anger among some pundits against
the unvaccinated cnn's don lemon said
they were acting in an idiotic
manner i don't think that helps anybody
certainly not going to change their
minds
and even among ordinary people the new
york times
just ran a story saying that there's a
lot more
anger now among those who have gotten
the shots
that the risk or the pandemic is allowed
to continue with this
recent surge in cases over the last
month or six weeks
because of people who aren't getting the
shots are we on
a dangerous path if we can't get off
these
dividing lines you know whether it's
vaccinated versus unvaccinated
which is just really a progression of
the masked
or unmasked debate which now
is kind of turning on its head because
you know even if you don't think if it's
a political statement to wear a mask or
not wear a mask
now if you're vaccinated let's say and
you wear a mask
just to be extra cautious some people
might think that you're wearing a mask
because you're not vaccinated
and be angry with you yeah well you know
people can make their own individual
decisions ultimately about whether they
should get vaccinated and whether they
should wear a mask even if they are
vaccinated i think the cdc is about to
muddle this picture further by
recommending that vaccinated people
wear mass in a number of situations
particularly indoor situations because
that's going to undercut the incentive
the whole
way this thing was sold was get the
vaccine
live something close to a normal life
you don't have to walk around with a
mask and now i think it's going to be
quite muddled and yes you know it
reminds me all too much of
uh the dispute over the 2020 election
each side says the other is lying donald
trump continues to
argue that there was a stolen election
uh the argument over the january six
committee
that just started his hearings in the
house and of course
we have these continuing partisan
arguments about the vaccine the
frustrating thing here
is that if more americans if 75
of americans instead of just roughly 50
uh were now fully vaccinated and we have
enough
available for that to be the case this
pandemic would be all but over in the
united states
just want to ask you one other question
after the veteran veteran affairs
became the first federal agency to
mandate that healthcare personnel be
fully vaccinated
could this be the beginning of broader
mandates even if you want to travel or
for schools for instance and could a
shift
like that be part of the answer to
getting more americans to take the
vaccines if you want to do this you got
to do that
we are absolutely moving in that
direction you now have new york city
with municipal workers the state of
california same thing and the va as you
mentioned
and other private businesses saying yes
if you want to do this you want to
attend a concert you want to go to this
sporting event you want to
go to our shopping malls you have to
show proof of vaccination
or a recent negative coven test
and that i do think if that were to
become more widespread
probably some of the people who are on
the fence or hesitant would say
all right i guess i got to give in
because i want to do these things
particularly if their job is at stake
what i worry about though is that that
will set off
an even bigger political backlash than
we have with the lockdowns last year
where people will feel their personal
freedom is being infringed upon where
people will feel like they don't
want to cooperate and they're being
forced to cooperate
despite whatever is their best judgment
for themselves
and their families so there's no easy
answer here but i think regardless
of the um resistance
among it's about 100 million americans
that we are all moving in the direction
of
more mandates but of course it's city by
city county by county
and business by business howard kurtz
host of media buzz we are always very
thankful for your time we appreciate it
thanks very much
this is janis dean with your fox news
commentary coming up
the rise back up in covet cases has led
to some concerns about the economy's
recovery
already being pressured by rising
inflation i'm always concerned about
inflation
but i also believe the federal reserve
has pointed out
that they think this is short-term in
nature while democrats like senator mark
warner think prices will come down
republicans worry about something else
democrats stay home bonus to workers who
remain
unemployed has slowed the recovery and
helped
keep workforce participation stagnant
senator mitch mcconnell referring to
extra federal unemployment assistance
many states have ended
first time jobless claims did increase
unexpectedly last week and more than 9
million americans remain out of work but
there is another problem with
unemployment benefits
some of the money has been mismanaged
even more has been stolen
the government accountability office
found that states overpaid nearly 13
billion in unemployment benefits in the
first
year of the pandemic hillary vaughn is a
fox business network correspondent
but really the department of labor
office of inspector general
has said that that number is actually
much bigger they came out with a
report in june that essentially
estimates that from the duration of
these boosted unemployment benefits
during the pandemic
from when they began to be rolled out to
when they are supposed to expire
in september there will have been 87
billion
in fraudulent and improper payments made
through that program to people who are
intentionally trying to take advantage
and use the system to get benefits that
they know
they are not entitled to and we're
talking about the federal money
here in this investigation these are
state unemployment systems
that are being targeted by fraudsters
and these states are
in charge of doling out the extra
federal
unemployment benefit on top of what they
already offer
unemployed people in their states and
the reason why that's relevant is
because
it's not a federal system that has high
cyber security
these are states that are fending for
themselves trying to use their
existing and many times archaic
unemployment systems to pay out these
benefits to people
and they're being targeted by people not
just in the united states it's
operations um all over the world of
essentially thieves trying to use stolen
identities
stolen social security information
plugging it in
on a mass wide scale level to the state
unemployment systems using fake email
addresses
fake accounts and then trying to
essentially
profit thousands and thousands of
dollars
through a wide scale operation of
essentially trying to manipulate and rig
the system so they can take advantage of
this there have been
many audits and studies from cyber
security experts that say
a lot of these essentially attacks
are coming from outside the u.s not just
people here who
are trying to get a little extra cash
but a wide scale effort
to fraudulently take advantage of the
system
yeah i saw one report where filings
from 170 different countries when they
investigated ip addresses and
websites so that that's really stunning
yeah and it's something that states are
having a hard time defending but
they at least have an idea of that
something
is off because in several states the
number of
initial jobless claims exceeded the
actual number of job losses
in that state so we know from a
pro-publica
report investigation that was published
yesterday
that arizona georgia hawaii nevada and
rhode island
had initial unemployment claims that
outnumbered their entire pool
of civilians that were claiming to be
out of work and so that kicks off states
that
this is a wide scale effort of people
targeting their systems and many times
they're targeting
many different states at the same time
and of course the states they were
overwhelmed
with actual people out of work back in
the spring especially of 2020 and into
the
summer and fall and so it's been hard
for them to keep up with even regular
claims let alone know which ones are
not real right and a lot of times it
unfortunately hurts the people that need
it most there are cases after
cases reported of people who need the
unemployment but they're
told we can't give you this benefit
because someone using your information
already has a claim filed in a different
state or we already paid out this
benefit to someone posing
as you so it does hurt real people what
are
your identities are being stolen what a
nightmare to be told that
you can't file because somebody stole
the money that was supposed to go to you
or would have gone to you and then
i don't even know what they do how do
they even fight that that would take a
long time i would think
yeah you know whenever your identity is
stolen it's it's a nightmare but this
information is basically
being marketed and sold on the dark web
so whenever they're
you know looking at the broader picture
whenever there is a cyber hack
a major hack and a lot of people get the
notification that you need to change
your password your information could
have been exposed well all of those
names and personal information is
essentially packaged and sold to people
who want to use it in different ways and
this trend
during the pandemic has been to buy
personal information being that was
stolen being sold on the dark web
plug that into states unemployment
filing systems
and try to squeeze out as much money as
you can
and the instances are really astounding
when you look at what
states are having to deal with vermont
is just one example
in june they said that in some months 90
of the claims that were being filed in
their system were fraudulent
so did you say 90 90
9-0 wow so it really is
jaw-dropping and puts into perspective
the need and the necessity to have
states
unemployment systems upgraded and to
have the money
to do that which ultimately president
biden did set aside 2 billion to do just
that because the federal government
has said this is an epidemic
and essentially a crisis and a security
crisis
to try to upgrade these systems so that
millions of dollars in federal aid that
it's supposed to go to people who need
it are
is not leaving the country and going to
essentially cyber criminals
now some of these accused criminals have
been
charged as a man in new york city
who allegedly got a million and a half
dollars in 10 months
there's a nigerian government official
accused of pocketing over three hundred
fifty thousand dollars and there was one
person according to the government
that used one social security number
to file unemployment insurance claims in
40 states and 29 of them paid
222 000 so this is really something
these people have really found a way
yeah there's right now or as of june 17
000 complaints and investigations
involving unemployment insurance fraud
being investigated
and complaints that have been filed
they've been able to recover
about 160 million dollars but again when
you compare that to how big the problem
is
and a lot of these systems are being
attacked today
and will continue to be attacked as long
as this remains
profitable for people so it's definitely
a problem
that the federal government is trying to
tackle and figure out the best way to
approach it
some proposals that have been floated
have been maybe we need a federal
system set up that is secure
and instead of letting states kind of
fend for themselves
and try to pay out these federal
benefits on their own because they're
clearly becoming targets
well we do know though from recent cyber
attacks that
it's not like the federal government is
immune to being
breached by hackers what is
congress doing about this they're
basically trying to close
loopholes in the system that really let
people who commit small claims fraud um
from kind of escaping accountability
and not letting them be prosecuted and
not letting the funds be recovered so
this is something that has support from
a bipartisan
group of senators really trying to
fine-tune the system
and modernize the system so that they
are able to catch
these cyber sleuth that are
taking advantage of the system even
outside the us
and make sure that the rules and
regulations in place
actually allow them to be prosecuted
and the funds to be recovered even on a
small scale
but then also on an extremely large
scale as well
the other big issue with unemployment
benefits that extra money the federal
government has been paying people
initially was six hundred dollars a week
then it was cut to three hundred bucks
but about half the states mostly with
republican governors have put a stop to
that
claiming it's paying people too much so
some
don't want to work to which president
biden replied with his much talked about
whispering
employers can't find workers i said yeah
pay them more well some workers have
gone to court getting those
extra benefits back in indiana and
maryland and there's a lawsuit in
florida too
i think we're seeing you know a labor
shortage
nationwide and part of the argument from
business owners that i've spoken to
anecdotally
is that people are making more money to
be unemployed than they would be if they
were at work and the bottom line is
a lot of these businesses can only raise
their wages so much
before they themselves are not able to
be profitable and have to close so
some states have said you know what
we're going to take away these benefits
early because
our businesses can't find the workers to
stay open
but there are some states that are
keeping it in place through
september and you know we'll see what
impact that has on their local economies
but
there are a lot of benefits being paid
to people and it is a challenge
for businesses to try to keep up but i
talked with
labor secretary marty walsh about this i
asked him if he
is worried that businesses are going to
have to close
if they're forced to pay double what
they normally would and he insisted that
in his mind he didn't think businesses
were paying double but we talked to
businesses who many of them were paying
minimum wage to 7.25
and are paying 15 plus that
sometimes with signing bonuses so that's
a huge change for a business to
pay double to have employees on the
payroll than they had to
pre-pandemic and a lot of them are
adapting and
a lot of democratic lawmakers say it's a
good thing that
workers are making more money and paying
more but on the flip side of that
what we hear from business owners is it
is a challenge and
they're even with those inflated wages
they still are having a very hard time
finding people
to come back to work and to go to work
is there a push
i know democrats do control congress and
there is a democrat in the white house
is there a push to maybe
extend this extra unemployment beyond
the september deadline where it ends
i think that that idea has been
floated but i don't see a real
push for that happening but it really is
up to
at the end of the day what is able to
get past and what the president will
sign
hillary vaughn fox business
correspondent
following the unemployment situation
thank you very much for joining us
thank you so much
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa just say
alexa play news from fox in fox news
it's the latest when you need it on
demand
from fox news and amazon alexa subscribe
to this podcast
at foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for
your fox news commentary janice dean
what's on your mind when representative
steve scalise
messaged me on friday afternoon that he
had received word
via a letter that the biden
administration's investigation
into the nursing home tragedy in new
york pennsylvania new jersey and
michigan
was being dropped i was incredibly sad
but not surprised representative scalise
had been helping me
and other families behind the scenes in
washington to try and get answers about
why
democratic governors ordered covet
infected patients into nursing homes in
the spring
of 2020. scalise sent me the letter
and gave me permission to post about it
on social media
i tweeted a terrible day for thousands
of families
in a letter to steve scalise the justice
department wrote that they were dropping
the nursing home investigations in all
states including new york
there will be no justice for our loved
ones and it feels like we've lost them
all over
again it was august of 2020 that the u.s
justice department's civil rights
division requested information from new
york in connection with the
controversial march 25th order
from the state's department of health
that required nursing homes to admit
covet 19
positive patients who were discharged
from hospitals
it also asked for records from
pennsylvania michigan and new jersey
states that have had the same mandates
that quote may have resulted in the
deaths
of thousands of elderly nursing home
residents the reason
here's what the deputy assistant
attorney general wrote last week
quote we have reviewed the information
provided by these states
along with additional information to the
department and based on that review
we have decided not to open a crypta
investigation
of any public nursing facilities within
new york pennsylvania or michigan at
this time
for months we were waiting for answers
as we waited
several sources were telling me the
investigation was being swept
under the rug in january of this year
a senior justice department official
confirmed to me
that new york state had failed to
provide any data
as of their october request not only did
governor andrew cuomo and his
administration
fail to provide any information to the
justice department
lawmakers countless reporters and
grieving families who have asked to be
disclosed he blamed
others for his disastrous mandate and
instead says
it's all politically motivated but i
will forever be grateful to former
attorney general william barr
and the trump administration for
launching the investigation
because this was the springboard to the
potentially more politically
damaging investigation here in new york
by the fbi
and the brooklyn u.s attorney's office
people have asked me if after last
week's terrible news from the doj
the other investigations will hold up my
answer is i have to believe our governor
will be held accountable in the end
there is another report coming out in
the next few weeks from new york
attorney general leticia james
that i hear will not be favorable and if
cuomo continues to hang around
until the election next november there's
always the hope
he will be voted out as for the other
states that had similar tragedies in
nursing homes
where is the accountability for their
leaders deadly decisions
now more than ever it's up to us the
people in these states
to use our voices and demand answers
from our elected officials
we must hold them accountable on behalf
of our families
especially those who have been silenced
forever
janice dean fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there
about the country and where we're going
subscribe to the ben dominic podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes